a dramedy with stoner Jesus awesome
our idiot brother
so I'd heard a lot of good things about
our idiot brother I heard it was like
this revolutionary comedy but for me it
was a dramedy actually it wasn't even a
dramedy it was like a drama with some
comedy in it like a couple scenes that's
it I mean I just didn't relate to this
movie at all probably because all the
characters in this movie I see on a
daily basis like someone took Seattle
turned it upside down shook it like a
pepper shaker or whatever fell out those
were the characters in this movie you
got each bag painters and artists really
pretentious independent filmmakers who
think they're better than everyone else
so they can make their little
documentary that's gonna be shown to
like NYU students on one day ever now
the people who are like you don't know
what you're talking about this movies
are two to four so Bravo performance an
elderly man
this isn't Starbucks Starbucks too
mainstream so yeah just not my thing I
mean I thought Paul Rudd was really good
in the movie like Paul Rudd this movie
is so naively nice it's like Steve
Carell and Dinner for Schmucks but not
as annoying I mean he's really brutally
honest not for the sake of being brutal
but just cuz he's honest he doesn't see
the darker side of reality like ever
who's really good to see him like steal
the show he's like Steve Carell in the
office how you're like dude this is his
role that was Paul Rudd in this movie I
was glad to see it but for me one
character and a really slow dramas not
enough to make up for the entire movie
this movie was marketed wrong everything
I've seen Marcus this movie as a comedy
it's not it's a drama I mean this last
summer we had Crazy Stupid Love that was
a really good drama comedy it had
characters alike it was well written I
thought it was interesting it was funny
and dramatic had everything for me our
Idiot Brother was a slow drama with a
couple funny parts you can't really come
off of Crazy Stupid Love into that there
were a couple of funny parts in couple
parts I really did like this is one
scene near the end where Paul Rudd says
something I was like dude I was glad to
see that actually the last 10 minutes of
the movie I liked a lot the other hour
and a half nah my thing and so this
movie is intuitive Falls and my dad I
mean long boring drawn-out and dull but
Paul Rudd was good I'm just saying so
yeah the movie disappointed me don't
know what to say so as for you guys
what's your favorite drama slash comedy
what's your favorite drama D is it work
comment below let me know and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more